speaking of tucker carlson
we've talked before about projection
when they talk a lot about something the
left is doing or should do
really we should be asking ourselves
aren't they the ones that are doing it
and tucker carlson is now calling for
democrats
to de-escalate their rhetoric
because it might actually lead to you
know anything from real-world violence
to extremism uh tucker that's what
you're actually doing and in fact when
tucker's rants appear verbatim in the
buffalo shooter's manifesto
you know that he's desperate to push
attention anywhere else that he can its
projection or the pot calling the kettle
black or you know what whatever analogy
or metaphor you want to use take a
listen to this from last night
because rhetoric has its own internal
logic right experience you can talk
yourself into things we've all done that
democrats are doing it right now and
what they're talking themselves into
right now is quote something worse it's
scary uh-oh it is time to pull back
it is time to de-escalate
otherwise this is going to get really
ugly really soon
well it did get really ugly really soon
a guy just went to buffalo
uh to search for black people to shoot
because he believed in the great
replacement or white replacement theory
which tucker and other of his right-wing
media cohorts have propped up he's
talking about the wrong people you know
it's a it's it's it's almost like he's
saying
these satanic pro-pedophile democrats
who are desperate to forcibly inject you
with a vaccine that's killing hundreds
of people
those people need to tone it down
because the rhetoric is getting
dangerous no the the rhetoric is coming
from their side and
one of the most notable
uh kind of narcissistic
traits
is these extreme double standards that
include projection
and accusing others of that which they
are actually guilty of doing it's one of
the many tactics that's often used by
narcissists and abusers and manipulators
and on and on and on their rhetoric
already incited an insurrectious riot on
january 6 2021
they talk about
dangerous illegals against whom we need
to be protected blah blah blah when
undocumented and documented immigrants
commit crime at a lower rate than
americans the constant gun rhetoric we
might need second amendment solutions we
might need to be ready to take up arms
against whoever talk of civil war which
we will talk about a little bit later
and the belief that they harbor that
increasingly violence is acceptable in
order to achieve political results it's
coming from their side save the
occasional you know eco-terrorist or
whatever it's almost all coming from
their side we'll have these clips on our
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor i'm thrilled about
because i sleep on a helix mattress at
home
and it's just the perfect mattress one
of the best things about helix is you
don't have to guess which mattress do i
need which one will be good for me you
take their famous sleep quiz on their
website you tell them your body type
your sleeping position your
back pain issues you might have and they
will pair you with a mattress that will
be perfect for you i took the sleep quiz
the mattress they suggested was exactly
what i needed i often get too hot at
night the mattress keeps me cool it's
not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right and i've just been
getting way better sleep you only buy a
mattress every decade or so don't get
stuck with something that's not perfect
for you and all helix mattresses come
with a 10-year warranty and they'll even
come to your house and pick it up within
a hundred days if you don't love it but
i think you will for a limited time
helix is offering up to 350 off all
mattress orders plus two free pillows at
helixsleep.com pacman it's the biggest
discount they've ever offered the link
is down below